in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Josh
and Brittany are with us hey guys how
are you hey welcome welcome where you
guys from Waverly Nebraska wow that's a
bit of a haul yeah all the way to
Tennessee when we're honored to have you
with us well thank you for having all
the way here to do your debt-free scream
yes yes how much have you paid off
one hundred and seventy eight thousand
oh my gosh how long did that take took
right out three years okay and your
range of income during those years
roughly eighty thousand just under a
hundred thousand okay very cool what do
y'all do for a living I'm an electrical
engineer okay and I stay at home my
momma very cool very well done one
hundred and seventy eight thousand is
that in the house not the house student
loans ah big student loans okay how much
did you have in student loan debt we had
about a hundred and forty thousand and
student loans Wow very heavy couple of
car loans and a small credit card too
okay so what happened three years ago
that flipped the switch and made you
guys go
hey we're cleaning this up man we had a
went to a marriage conference and talked
about our greatest fears and I shared
that I was afraid of being able to
provide for our family in a while woke
something up and me and woke something
up and Brittany where we said we got to
do something different and at that time
we had found the podcast and started
listening and so we bought the book it's
all the money make over and started our
journey then Wow so you started it off
the book yes and you come home we go
okay our greatest fear is this
overwhelming student loan debt I mean
it's just like this this monster in the
closet at your house you know yeah every
night when you lay your head down on the
pillow he's in there banging on the door
I mean that's real innit yeah that's
very real stuff so tell me how it
started you you know I see what you're
saying you got the book and so you sat
down the first night to do a budget
right John no josh was really into it to
begin with and I was a little bit
hesitant but then we took FPU and
started paying with cash
slowly by slowly watching the numbers go
down and it it worked
yeah so you went through Financial Peace
University was it at your church or a
local church or what your church what's
the name the church Faith Lutheran and
Lincoln great very cool very cool
that's nice awesome so you go into the
class and and you know Josh is like okay
we're doing this I'm all and I'm on
Brittany's like so what happened
Brittany to you in the first class
rotate I didn't want to sell my van oh
we did sell mom's car we sold the van
what did it bring what did we sell it
for about thirteen thousand a okay and
then how did that decision happen tell
me well we had a Durango also and we
tried to sell that and realized we owed
too much on it and we couldn't get out
of it what we needed okay the man was
not upside down no so that thirteen came
clear then what are you driving I'm
driving at different van now we've gone
through we drove we we sold the van we
sold the Durango oh you did get rid of
Marengo okay eventually after we paid
more off on that and then we went
through to hoop tees yes no antifreeze
leaking toggle switch to turn the lights
on who DS there you go a couple of
throwaway cars yeah yes but now here you
are three years later and you paid off
$178,000 you make $100,000 a year I
think you can save up and buy a nice car
now yeah I paid cash for it right yes
yeah yeah so was it worth it absolutely
absolutely so selling that man you sold
everything you told the cars I mean you
guys were all in what was other than
that what was the hardest part of this
process for you all well we we did get
some help at the end to just in three
years we paid off 61 thousand by
ourselves and then we received a little
inheritance money to finish off the rest
of it oh wow look at who passed away my
grandmother yeah yeah so her legacy
moved on yeah so was she good with money
oh yes yes both my grandparents that she
left her grandkids sixty grand yeah yeah
yes and so our more so
suspect she's in heaven smiling with
what you did with that huh yes yes my
grandpa - my grandpa was a really hard
worker yeah yeah it's very cool it's a
wonderful thing and then you take that
debt freedom now and you turn it into a
financial legacy for your kids yes and
your grandkids yeah very cool yeah and
our kids have been in this with us the
entire way now what are your kids names
an HS Sayla is 11 Jonah is nine gillian
at 6 and Samuels 4 and they came all the
way from Nebraska with you they just in
the car oh yes it did and there's a lot
of miles with a lot of kids the beatings
are paid off all right you guys are fun
very cool so now someone's listening to
this because there's so many people
overwhelmed out there and they're
hearing 178,000 paid off in 3 years and
it's just like when your friend loses
100 pounds or something what do we
always say or say how did you do that
so tell people what the secret depending
off 178,000 and three years for us that
having a goal was the biggest thing that
the budget was our we had to have our
budget in place I've always budgeted I'm
a nerd and but we always looked at what
we spent after we spent it and so
getting our budget in order was key but
having a goal with with that much debt
we were looking at six seven eight nine
years and just to get our arms around
that and to stay focused was tremendous
sweet so we set small steps I came home
with a with a big chart that showed how
much we had paid off and the the read
was real little and Brittany about had a
heart attack so he she started small
charts and set goals along the ways
there we go
we could reward ourselves with little
things like ice cream you feel the
progress yeah and then I'm a visual
person so we Josh had heard some someone
call in and they counted marbles or
their debts and so we didn't have that
memorable so we went with beans and we
had to dirty for the marble exactly we
had two jars one with the beans that
we've paid off and one that we have left
and then
every time we would pay off a debt the
kids would move the beans from the jars
very cool color on our charts so the
kids were in on it so they know what mom
and dad have done yes
so you've more than just paid off the
debt they've seen how to handle money
yeah so you really have changed your
family tree yes sir yeah you've really
changed everything yeah I have to hide
our debit card from them because they
think it's a credit card plastic surgeon
yes way to go kiddos I love it that's
fun all right we'll gather them all
around over with you and they've been so
good and I'm sure they've been
practicing all the way from Nebraska
they have so very very cool all right
it's Josh and Brittany Sayla Jonah
Gillian and Samuel and a hundred and
seventy eight thousand dollars paid off
in three years making eighty to a
hundred selling everything and grandma
puts the icing on the cake count it down
let's there a debt free scream three two
one
yeah baby good job kids very well done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head
and make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind